so with all that
i am very excited to introduce our next
speaker
and author of this amazing book when i
read this book
i just said this is fun to read of
course it's full of great knowledge but
it's a really enjoyable read
it was really really really great and
i first came across him i'm not sure how
we actually get introduced but he spoke
at the meetup a number of years ago
it was one of our more popular talks it
was pretty awesome
and he says that
the first language he ever fell in love
with was
r so please welcome
john to the stage
his music should be playing there we go
so is my audio on i am live
this is happening okay it is
happening hello world how's it going
alright so i assume you can also see my
screen
i'm uh oh not yet okay perfect
uh good to know let me press this
button that looks like a screen and then
share the correct one
there we go how about that
jolly good all right so today's talk
is a battle to the death
between tensorflow 2 and pi torch
i can't wait to dig into all the content
with you
and i'd also like to note that there are
some beautiful illustrations in here
from
my book deep learning illustrated which
has this great sticker that i think
everyone in the us has been sent one of
these
um and uh yeah
so agle bassins was the illustrator of
deep learning illustrated
and you will see a number of her
illustrations in here
from that book as well as some that
aren't even in the book so for example
here's a beautiful illustration of my
dog
oboe who might be in the video at some
point
so whoa what's that guy doing here
now that must have been a very slow news
day
uh well in january 2017
that beautifully quaffed news anchor
provided me the opportunity to give an
intro to deep learning
at his open statistical programming
meetup in new york as you just mentioned
in the intro
and to give you a sense of how quickly
the worlds of stats and
machine learning change only three years
ago that was the
first lecture on deep learning at
jared's meetup the first of what would
turn out to of course be many
and at that talk i met someone named
deborah williams
um from the publisher pearson and since
then she's had me slaving away
to create 40 hours of videos and dozens
of online trainings on deep learning
culminating in the release
of deep learning illustrated in november
of last year
congratulations to the winner of that
book mr foster i believe it is
um if you do come to the our conference
next year i will seriously give you a
physical copy and sign it
i would love to do that for you all
right so across all of the teaching that
i now do
on deep learning a single question is
asked more
than all of the others combined and that
is
so tensorflow or
pi torch given the popular demand
of that question i couldn't resist
dedicating my lecture
to the topic today so first
a couple of slides on deep learning in
case you weren't already
aware of kind of a high level what's
important about it so
this guy his name beyond the ka he
actually works in new york it's 770
broadway at the
facebook he's the head of facebook ai
research and he works at four days a
week and then one day a week he lectures
in the math department
at new york university joshua bengio
he's up in montreal
he teaches at the university of montreal
and has a startup called element ai
and then jeff hinton he's in toronto
where he leads
the google brain team and is a professor
emeritus at the university of toronto
these three gentlemen were awarded last
year the turing prize which is the
equivalent of the nobel prize
for computer science for their work
on deep learning so we're going to
particularly in
particularly in the interest of time i'm
going to focus on
a landmark innovation by
jeff hinton by his lab so in 2012
him and alex krashevsky and ilya
susgaver from his lab
released this architecture that you now
see
on the left side of my slide so this
architecture is named after the first
author on the paper
alex krazewski so it's called alexnet
and
the key idea that i want you to get from
this architecture
is that it has many layers so on the far
left here
if you're inputting some input image
here we have an input image of a cad
then you have several layers of
artificial neurons
which are um they're designed to mimic
in a loose way
the way that biological brain cells work
so biological neurons
and these artificial neurons
through having several layers of them
they are allowed to
have increasingly complex increasingly
abstract representations of
whatever input data they're trying to
map
to an output so there's actually some
examples here along the bottom
so the first layer of alexnet has 96 of
these artificial neurons and
i've shown here what each of those 96
artificial neurons is specialized to
detect so in the first layer
you can see that each neuron is
specialized to detect
a straight line at a different
orientation
and then the second layer can recombine
those straight lines into curves and
corners so you see
examples from the artificial neurons in
that layer here
and then in the third layer again it it
recombines and allows more abstraction
and so as you get deeper and deeper and
deeper
you get these increasingly complex
increasingly abstract visual
representations
until the model is able to make a very
accurate guess
as to what uh image has been
put at the front so if this was trained
to distinguish cats from dogs horses and
flowers
then when you input an image of a cat
you will get an output that says hey
there's a 99
probability this is a cat a one percent
uh yeah a one percent chance is a dog a
zero percent chance it's a force
and so on so that's
deep learning in a nutshell and in 2012
when that alex net architecture was
released
it made a huge splash so jeff hinton and
his team
released that architecture into
something called the imagenet large
scale visual recognition competition
which is still today
the premiere machine vision competition
in the world
and you can see that in the first three
years of the competition
all of the algorithms introduced were
what i call
traditional machine learning algorithms
so these could involve this could be
regression
support vector machines decision trees
basically any kind of machine learning
that isn't deep learning and
whether traditional is a good name for
it or not don't worry about that it's
just
so that i can distinguish it from what
deep learning is so
all of the leading machine vision
approaches were
from these other realms of machine
learning up until 2012
except for that one algorithm entry
of alexnet and as you can see it
absolutely crushed
all of the other competitions so year
over year there was
no performance improvement in any of the
other
approaches and so had not
alex had been entered you would have
seen really no improvement year over
year
but instead there was a 30 improvement
relative to the previous year's best
model and so
everybody took notice academics people
working on commercial applications of
machine learning
everyone started working on deep
learning architectures
and by 2013 all of the top models were
deep learning
models and it has been the case since
it's also
worth noting that a team from microsoft
research asia
got a head of human accuracy in 2015 so
that's
kind of an interesting benchmark the
machine's taking over
so in one slide to summarize the main
idea of the power of this deep learning
approach
is that with the other approaches what i
was calling the traditional machine
learning approaches whether these are
yeah regression support vector machine
random force what have you with those
approach with those approaches
we typically spend the vast majority of
our time
becoming an expert in our data and
extracting
meaningful features out of the data so
writing functions to take in raw
input images or raw video or raw sound
and output what we think might lead to a
meaningful signal
so the vast majority of our time maybe
80 or 90
of our time as a traditional machine
learning practitioner is spent
extracting features from the data and
then we spend a minority of our time
actually training the models
in deep learning that is typically
turned on its head
where we might spend little to none of
our time
engineering features out of the raw data
instead relying
on our deep learning models to do that
automatically which is something they
can do
because of all these layers so
those layers can progressively and
automatically extract increasingly
abstract
increasingly uh complex features
allowing us to as you can see from the
preceding slide with the with the
performance of the ils vrc
this approach of letting the machines
automatically detect what the most
important features are
for predicting some outcome that we'd
like it to learn to predict
that approach is more powerful than
trying to do
the feature extraction manually
so there are some limitations with deep
learning of course typically we require
i mean i'm speaking in broad strokes
here but typically we we
require larger data sets to make it work
we
almost always require much more compute
and so
it's because of those reasons that deep
learning wasn't prominent until 2012 so
up until 2012
a lot of these ideas there have been a
few theoretical advances in the last
decade
but for the most part the theory was in
place it was a matter of having
the compute and the data storage
to make deep learning rush ahead
of traditional machine learning around
that 2012 point
since 2012 we've seen deep learning take
over the world
in millions of applications so not just
in machine vision like you see here you
know the face recognition on your phone
that allows it to automatically open
but by 2014 2015 deep learning started
spilling into natural language
processing so
any device that does voice recognition
is using deep learning to do that
generative adversarial networks allow
you to
create really stunning
fake artwork based on some particular
inputs so in this case
this generative adversarial network was
trained on
high definition celebrity photos and
these two people do not exist but they
sure look like real people
and then another big application area
for deep learning is deep reinforcement
learning
where for example in just a couple of
years
machines have been able to overtake
people at some very
complex intuitive games such as
the board game go thanks to
deep reinforcement learning so all of
these topics that cover in detail in
deep learning illustrated if you're
interested in learning more
for now we need to actually move on to
talking about tensorflow and pytorch
i'm already halfway through the talk in
terms of time so
um given how powerful and transformative
deep learning is
hundreds of software libraries have
sprung up in recent years
to make designing testing and deploying
deep learning models
easy so here are
some of the most popular libraries today
in terms of a
google search frequency so
tensorflow you can see for many years
was the front runner
it used to compete with another library
called fianno
in 2016 2017 but
people don't work on fiano anymore all
those people moved to google
uh to work on tensorflow and
in those years in 2016 2017 there was
this library keras
which was designed as a high level api
to make building models initially in
thiano
and then later in fianno and tensorflow
and now primarily in tensorflow
very easy so the low level tensorflow is
relatively complex
but keras made it very easy and as of
the tensorflow 2.0 release
which happened in late 2019 and i'll
talk about that a bit more
in the coming slides keras is a built-in
module of tensorflow 2 and it is the
recommended way
that the the tensorflow developers have
for
how you should build your neural
networks now
there are a couple other libraries mxnet
which
is supported by amazon and blue cntk the
cognitive
toolkit which was supported by microsoft
and as you can see they're not nearly as
popular though maybe if i did this in
bing
cntk would be a bit more popular than me
doing this in google
and um so other than those you can see
that there's one
other library that is eating into
the uh the share of tensorflow and keras
and that is pie torch in green so that
is officially supported by facebook
and it was initially being developed
just by one gentleman at facebook
and today we have a lot of people using
both
pi torch and tensorflow paris
so in particular looking at job postings
from april of this year
you can see that tensorflow has a
modest lead over pytorch in terms of
being mentioned in the job postings
however across the united states states
in major urban areas
a sizable portion of job postings
uh do mention pytorch relative to the
proportion that mentioned tensorflow so
seattle seems to be particularly a big
lover of
pi torch where 77 of
job postings relative to tensorflow
mention
pytorch and so across these metro areas
there's a 60
average so in either case both of these
libraries are
very prominent definitely the two most
important deep learning libraries
there's one other library that i didn't
have in that google search chart called
cafe
because it turns out people like coffee
a lot more than they like deep learning
libraries so i can't really
uh include that in a google search
so obviously today we're primarily
talking about pi torch and tensorflow so
i'll focus on those two columns here
a big difference between these
two deep learning libraries was that for
up until the tensorflow 2.0 release in
uh late 2019 late last year
tensorflow had what's called a symbolic
programming style which is shared with
cafe and this symbolic programming style
was a little bit difficult to get used
to it was an unusual way of programming
and if i had time
i would show you examples of how that
worked but you essentially have to have
at least this
three-step process in order to execute
even very simple lines of code like
adding
two variables to each other
whereas with the imperative approach you
are
able to in the way that we've gotten
used to in our studio or jupyter
notebooks today
just executing a line of code and having
the addition or the multiplication or
whatever mathematical operation
we have in that line of code just
imperatively execute in real time and
produce a result
so one of the reasons why
torch or so torch actually really
only works in lua or c
however so pi torch is a complete
rewrite
of this torch library for python
and one of and one of the big reasons
why pytorch became so popular
in the last couple of years is because
it was so much easier
to use because of this imperative
programming style so this
with tensorflow 2.0 that was one of the
big things that
the folks working on tensorflow were
racing to do was to get
an imperative programming style in there
as well
and so as you can see in here tensorflow
is
uh supported in lots of languages
including r
and i'm going to talk about that
momentarily it is primarily supported in
python and c
and it is officially supported in all of
these other languages
the ones in brackets are unofficially
supported and i'll talk more about the
r1 on the next slide
so specifically digging into the
differences between pi torch and
tensorflow
you can if you're familiar with python
then you can think of pi torch as being
numpy
but optimized for using on gpus
and gpus allow deep learning models to
train
typically much more quickly than you can
by using cpus only so that's important
both pytorch and tensorflow support gpus
but pytorch is a lot more just like that
numerical python package
um so very very easy to use if you're
already familiar with numpy
tensorflow on the other hand was ported
to python from c plus plus
so when you get so it's if you're used
to python it's
not pythonic really it's kind of clunky
to use
lots of things happen in ways that you
wouldn't expect and that's because of
this porting
and then when you get an error you get
these really long stack traces
that typically don't make any sense and
so you need to just copy and paste
whatever that error was
into google and then you get a stack
overflow result and you copy and paste
whatever that stack overflow solution
was into your code
whereas in numpy because or sorry in pi
torch because it was designed for python
it's very easy to use it behaves exactly
as you'd expect
the stack traces are easy to understand
and go along with
now for r specifically there isn't an
official
pie torch implementation however via the
reticulate python interface
you can use the r torch library
tensorflow on the other hand
has a well supported interface that is
created by the wonderful folks at
rstudio
who also have a hexagonal sticker that
was sent to you
um so both of these libraries allow you
to do
what's called auto differentiation which
is a kind of partial derivative calculus
that is critical
for training machine learning models and
i have a slide coming up where i'll show
you a quick example of that happening
and pi torch allows this process to be
dynamic so you can very easily have
um data sets of all different kinds of
sizes flowing into your model and you
can differentiate on those and trade
on those in tensorflow up until the 2.0
release and still today with a 2.0
release if you're using keras to build
your models
you have a static graph which means that
you cannot have different sized
data inputs they need to all be
consistent in terms of sizing
pytorch has something called the fast.ai
api that allows you to build models very
easily
i think too easily i think that keras
the keras api that's offered in
tensorflow is a really nice middle
ground if you're getting started in deep
learning
um because of the short stack traces and
because of how pythonic it is debugging
is much easier in pi
torch the advantage of tensorflow is
that it's much more widely adopted
in order to make pytorch performance
in production while also being
imperative and easy to use in real time
there's something called the torch grip
just in time compilation
scripts that allow you to deploy your
pytorch models models into production
efficiently
whereas tensorflow has many in addition
to those kinds of compilation
scripts it has many other kinds of
support libraries for
distributed training with tensorflow
serving or deploying models
into someone's browser in javascript
into embedded devices or phones with
tensorflow lite
and the tf data and tfio libraries allow
you to very easily
have all of your pre-processing happen
[Music]
inside of the tensorflow model so
overall pi torch is more enjoyable for
model design
tensorflow is better for production
deployments i'm going to have to skim
over these slides but i just wanted to
give you a sense of what it's like
um doing various operations in pytorch
versus tensorflow
so here we are creating a simple um
vector tensor as you can see things just
kind of
look nicer and cleaner in pi torch
relative to tensorflow but you get a bit
more information in tensorflow
you can see more information in this
jupiter notebook
i am out of time so i'll just quickly
rush through these
final slides um for the automatic
differentiation that i described a
couple slides ago
so for example if you wanted to find uh
if you take the derivative of y equals x
squared and then you plug in the number
five
for x you'll find that the derivative of
y with respect to x
at x equals five is equal to ten and so
to calculate that with automatic
differentiation in pi
torch and tensorflow it's easy in either
library
but it's definitely easier in pytorch
you have these weird with statements in
tensorflow to make it happen
and in terms of creating a model it's
about
exactly as easy in pi torch versus
tensorflow keras
in terms of training a model it is way
easier in tensorflow keras
in the keras module than it is in
pytorch but if you like having control
or if you're a little bit more
experienced with deep learning or if
you'd like to have dynamic input sizes
then you'll definitely want to be using
pi torch instead of the tensorflow
chara's way of doing it in a single line
so in conclusion tensorflow or pri
torch well the answer is both
so if you understand one it's easy to
understand the other
if you're using deep learning
professionally you'll run into both all
the time anyway as we saw from those job
description stats
there's a more granular perspective on
model training in pi
torch which makes a little more complex
than keras
but ultimately pi torch is more flexible
than keras
pi torch is more fun and easier to debug
because the stack traces are
straightforward tensorflow
in contrast has a stronger open source
ecosystem
for distributed training and more
flexible model deployment options
so if you're brand new to deep learning
i'd recommend starting with a tensorflow
2 keras module
then moving to pytorch once you're
comfortable with it for example by
working through my book deep learning
illustrated
through my book deep learning
illustrated in which we do
exactly that and also you can use
the onyx open neural network exchange
library
to transfer between tensorflow and
pytorch
seamlessly so you could use pytorch for
that fun interactive model development
and then when you're ready for your
beefy deployment distributed training
or deployment into various kinds of
systems like javascript uh browsers and
so on
then you can translate your model from
pytorch into tensorflow to do that
so yeah uh yeah if you're new to deep
learning i definitely recommend
the process that i just followed on the
last slide um there is a
as a conference attendee you get a deep
deep discount on any
um data science books offered by pearson
so 40 off starting persona videos check
out uh that link
and this checkout code to get those
discounts and yeah please do stay in
touch thank you very much for being here
would love to have met you in person
consider signing up for my email
newsletter i push out
lots of free videos on machine learning
foundations
and deep learning as you saw examples
from on the preceding slides
connect on linkedin mention that you
were in today's talk i'd love to be able
to kind of put a name
to an experience and a face to an
experience and follow along with your
career
particularly if you're in new york
there's a good chance we'll see each
other soon anyway
as i mentioned i post lots of videos on
youtube and i tweet some stuff as
well and i've got a podcast
the artificial neural network news
network where you can stay up to date on
the latest in machine learning news
all right i'm all done thank you very
much
for your attention and i look forward to
meeting you in the future and answering
your questions
thank you very much john as a quick note
i noticed you mentioned
our torch via reticulate there are
rumors abound
that there's going to be native torch
bindings in our without going to
articulate
so that's going to be a lot of fun when
that officially comes out
another tradition we have at this
conference is we usually start putting
up bloody marys around 8 am so if anyone
has a beer
now's a good time to drink one